et maintenant
[Musique]
h
saleh
voici maria pacôme
[Musique]
tu sais pas
maria pacôme bonsoir soir
parce que tu disais je pouvais pas tu le
prennes mal géré s'envoler quand tu
penses à navès djamel way qui n'était
pas intéressant ouais enfin ceci étant
le décor il est mieux depuis que tu la
nique et moins cher si je travaillais
une veste tout de suite oui si tu
voulais pas porter ce nom est atteint
comme rebond soir alors je vois
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus roger hart
qui vous habite donald cardwell kivu
décor vous êtes plutôt habillé comme un
cas comme un journaliste journalistes en
irak green fees de leçons d'un 8e
particulièrement des petits gilets mois
correspondants de guerre
tu peux la le look ça va maria très bien
bien
alors donc j'étais à la fiche de mauvais
esprit de patrick alessandrin avec
thierry lhermitte ophélie winter
clémentine célarié michel muller je cite
attaché de presse est toujours inscrite
gavard je sais pas si elle est en
coulisses catherine laurence astrid et
l'a donc astrid surveille et si des fois
je parlais pas assez bien du du film
mauvais esprit tu pourrais venir voilà
alors légèrement lé charme en alsace et
que c'était mon assistante astrid oui
mais je sais qu'on a vu avec la gaule du
matin
elle n'avait pas dit ça je peux vous
dire en tous les cas que je l' ai
toujours respectés elle n'a pas dit ça
non plus alors le plus qu'à écouter
c'est très simple clic sur les esprits
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui n'a
vraiment pas de pot dans la vie qui est
incarné par michel muller jusqu'au jour
où il meurt renversé par une voiture
conduite par thierry lhermitte et il va
renaître dans la peau du bébé que
thierry lhermitte va avoir avec ophélie
winter et il est prêt à tout pour se
venger bref c'est une espèce de chien
orné comme on dit sur les affiches du
film c'est une excellente idée de
vraiment c'est un film très bonne idée
ces gens de scénarii que les américains
nous rachète en général parce que c'est
vraiment c'est très fort la
réincarnation du ch dans le bébé alors
évidemment chaque fois qu'il voit
thierry lhermitte le déteste nouveau des
choses alors alessandra avait déjà fait
15 août que tu as un bon film 15 août et
13 août il a toujours des gens qui ont
des bonnes idées
alors vous vous êtes la mer donc de
thierry lhermitte la belle-mère de fait
des winter et vous êtes appelés à un
moment à la rescousse pour contrôler cet
affreux bébé oui enfin un monstre vous
bien me dire oui les deux monstres est
ailleurs il ya trois mois ya le petit
alors quand vous aimez ces sacs et ma
tante et d'ailleurs qui m'a fait que
vraiment ophélie winter c'est une
horreur là moi je suis une horreur on se
traite mais comme mais vraiment c'est
assez vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya des
rapports ya pas il n'y a pas un sourire
las des rapports d'une violence entre
windsor et vous
rainy river qui n'existe pas jamais
jamais jamais moi je connais pas très
très violent c'est très très violent et
bien alors vous maria pacôme donc dans
ce film vous n'êtes pas comme est ce qu
un diable vous êtes là belle-mère
foldingue quoi voilà une fois de plus
fall down on chante chante mais pas
folle dingue
pas folle la bonne dame est une méchante
femme agressive elle n'aime pas sa belle
si elle adore son peut même son le petit
bébé elle l'a d'or mais méchamment elle
dit à un moment oui bon ça va
faut pas faire chier un cadre à yop la
lui refusant le elle est vraiment
odieuse vous êtes un petit peu quand
même là la barre joue dans ce film même
s'il est moins que que vous l'avez été
oui j'en étais là s'ailleurs je me suis
arrêté car en guise et c'est pour ça
vous êtes devenu auteur c'est parce
qu'avant vous aviez marre de faire ce à
quoi le
voilà vous avez compris que les pièces
que vous écriviez n'était pas pire que
celle qu'on vous apporter c'était ma
minute alors qu'ils avaient dit anna il
ya des pièces bien meilleur non mais a
pas envoyé à la et en plus vous avez
découvert que quand on touche les droits
d'auteur c'est plus sympa ça c'est
surtout ça qui était très belle a été
très agréable très très agréable mais
très marias pognon mais qu'est ce qu'il
raconte comme imbécillité là mais bien
sûr que non j'ai pas vous côtoyez ça
vous avez de quoi vous arrêter de
travailler quand même j'y pense le seco
non mais j'y pense
bon bah on va piquer ton ton pognon
non mais en fait ce qui est terrible et
maria pacôme et ça arrive souvent avec
les avec les grands acteurs c'est que
vous avez été bon j'ai fait une carrière
formidable vous avez réjouit nombre de
fois et en fait votre rêve secret
c'était de jouer tchekhov cette fameuse
cette fameuse phrase que vous adorez ne
me secouez pas comme ça je suis plein de
larmes
oui dites le moi comme vous l'auriez dit
ne se crée pas comme ça je suis plein de
larmes
ouais voilà ce qu'on a raté non
maria pacôme pendant la guerre votre
père était déporté à buchenwald et
l'époque vous êtes senti d'un seul coup
très seul trait libre et vous vous êtes
dirigés vers le vers le théâtre au cours
simon
vous dites plutôt café d'à côté
d'ailleurs le plat oui oui n'ont jamais
été une femme d'aider des cours je crois
que je me suis faite toute seule comme
ça alors ciment au cours simon vous a
dit t'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde vous dire quoi que vous
aviez une présence
oui c'est ça ouais alors
bonsoir ça
au pouvoir
je vois je vraiment ces moustiques je
vois que tu es tombé sur le sur le même
plan je viens de te soutenir ce que tu
es un peu sol ça te va très bien oui toi
aussi je te regarder à l'écran c'est bon
c'est bien mais à un moment donné c'est
pénible mais c'est un début de
l'émission ça va mais quand il veut être
où il alors de la matin c'est que j'ai
vu des trucs pas vu j'ai vu monsieur de
gaulle donc l'amiral de gaulle un croisé
gabriel cohn bendit le gabriel cohn
bendit lui a dit bonjour
gabriel cohn-bendit il a tiqué le vieux
disque est drôle c'est que c'est des
rencontres par procuration ouais c'est
assez ordinaire de cohn bendit avec le
fils de 2 go oui voilà c'est ça qui est
marrant et lui la tique est enfin en
fait donc son fils
mais non il a marqué le coup c'est
rigolo alors c'est que maria pacôme est
venu au théâtre dans la guerre sans père
était déporté à buchenwald et qu'elle
allait au cours simon enfin plutôt à
côté du court ciment dans un district
s'appelle le villars est alors sciemment
réellement c'est mieux en face d'accord
et simon lui a dit cette phrase
mémorable tu n'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde ce qui veut dire que
tout de suite il avait vu que vous aviez
une présence quoi c'est peut-être moi un
peu pour me flageller qui rajoutait tu
n'es pas une beauté
l'espagne pour sa part maintient un peu
excessif il a dit ouah mais tu as une
présence
maria a un moment faut arrêter de s'auto
flageller ça au palace devrait pas
déconner alors évidemment ce n'est pas
beaucoup d'argent à l'époque et simon
vous a dit toujours lui le cours simon
tu peux pas payer mais tu as une gueule
tu investis à la part ajouté mia il a
dit que je suis sans dire tu n'es pas
une beauté marie tu vas peut-être donc
n'étant pas une beauté tu vas pas perdre
ton dieu tu restes tu vois il avait je
crois qu'il avait confiance en moi même
si vous voyez que je travaillais pas
beaucoup il a dit tu restes ouest et
vous êtes resté je suis parti c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque vous aviez pas beaucoup
d'argent vous étiez soutien continue
d'ailleurs arrêté non mais c'est vrai
qu'un 16 ans à ses anciens amants mariés
à 16 ans vous étiez apprenti chez un
fabricant de chaussures oui mais bien
sûr j'étais en plein sahara est à fond
de moi là oui parce qu'il vient
travailler parce que papa était dans la
grille quand on était tout jeune frère
et moi et que fallait il a fallu tant et
c'est un peu dur mais c'est dur pour
plein de gens ouais et c'est l'époque où
maria pacôme mon cher moustiques étaient
donc mannequin vous et des photos
publicitaires et à ce moment là donc
j'étais pas belle mais c'est l'époque on
peut le dire je crois ce soir parce que
la prescription
vous avez failli un peu mal tourné à
l'époque non oui oui c'est une présence
j'étais le fait que mon père était
arrêtée on était des mômes et que je
fais un homme très sévère le fait
d'avoir cette liberté du jour au
lendemain est très dangereuse mais parce
que parce que d'abord j'étais très très
bien élevés mais très durement partir de
là voilà et maintenant tu es un peu
faible voilà donc j'ai eu la chance
c'est la sainte le théâtre le théâtre
vous a sauvé d'une vie dissolue maria
pacôme je sais mes rencontres m'ont
sauvé crois beaucoup plus à entendre le
théâtre nô et puis voilà cette histoire
de soutien de famille a duré toute votre
vie parce que vous avez toujours été
ensuite celle qui a inventé le fric à la
maison à l'abri
alors évidemment ça vous amener à
accepter des rôles qui était pas
obligatoirement ce que vous espériez
étant adolescente je n'ai vraiment pas
vendre du tout de ce que j'ai joué il ya
jamais une chose honteuse dans mais
vraiment quand tu étais vraiment trop
moche je disais non je ne sais pas j'ai
jamais eu je n'étais pas habité par le
théâtre j'ai jamais eu 13 ans que
j'aimais bien j'aime bien écrire
j'aimerais bien jouer
j'aimais bien la vie surtout si tôt que
j'avais gagné un que je gagnais free que
j'arrêtais très vite d'ailleurs et je
partais de la bagnole foutait le camp je
dépense mon fric et je revenus mon agent
me disent toujours mais tu feras jamais
de carrière mais je m'en foutais moi et
j'avais là cette chance extraordinaire
de retrouver tout de suite quelque chose
à faire est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement maria pacôme que vous avez
eu la carrière que vous méritiez a tant
donné flemmarde comme je le suis et
grillons us et c'est vraiment c'est
incohérent la manière dont je vis c'est
une suite une vraie chance un jeu mérite
pas cette carrière je méritais pas mieux
je regrette mais moi moi je regrette de
ne pas avoir fait du cinéma mais avoir
été voir des metteurs en scène et ça il
faut le faire c'est souvent se déplacer
j'ai jamais rien fait tout ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est arrivé et je crois que j'ai
du talent c'est pour ça donc ayant des
qualités bon ben j'ai surnager benjamin
commun en tout cas je sais pas si tu le
sais maria pacôme a été mariée avec
maurice ronet savez oui quand même le
plus beau de tous n'étant pas une beauté
c'est une chanson le plus bel homme du
cinéma et on était très amoureux que
c'est l'été écoutez on était drôlement
mignons tous les deux étaient dingues de
vous maurice ronet vous imaginez le
nombre d'enfants qui sont jalouses de
vous ce soir
alors ce qui est très marrant c'est qu'à
l'époque jamais imaginé ça à l'époque où
vous étiez avec maurice ronet vous étiez
un peu baba cool avant l'heure quoi vous
êtes parti dans le bouddhisme même nom
on a fait des choses insensées ont été
mitigés retrouver à moustiers sainte
marie et on trouvait là la vieille terre
pour refermer on a fait des choses
dingues on abandonnait tout ce qui était
théâtre c'est fou c'est fou on était pas
on était tout un groupe là il y avait
des gens même un peu qui après peintre
tout ça on est le théâtre était bien
loin
on voulait une autre vie
vous rêviez d'une autre vie moi j'ai
commencé à être un peu connu j'avais 33
dans encore un petit peu
et avant ça m'était complètement égal
j'avais envie de vous lui de faire des
choses comme c'est vrai que ça s'est
terminé en vendant de la lavande au bord
des routes
en effet toute mignonne alaoui avec une
amie on avait jamais moins d'acheter des
morceaux de 2,2 de tissus comme ça que
c'est tout voilà on éteignait toutes les
couleurs on s'est dit que moi j'étais
très à droite pour faire ça on quedal
avant moi tu parles tu es tout bronzé
avec l'allée du jusqu'ici et puis on
arrêter les voitures ont fait un fric
fou avec sa reine on faisait des trucs
comme ça pour eux c'est pas cool avant
la wii
ouais alors messieurs les voit souvent
je compare michèle laroque à elvire
popesco parce qu'elles sont romaine
toutes les deux mais je crois que
j'aurais pu aussi vous comparez à maria
pas condamné michèle laroque et
maintenant donc on va faire comme si
l'âme d'ophélie winter était entré dans
votre corps maria pacôme
imaginez un moment où soyez habités
comme ça je suis à fait lille vous êtes
ophélie interview dans la peau de
fellini
ferrer qu'on vous appelle ophélie ou aux
faits lie au félin au pelage ophélie
vous êtes toujours très très très sexy
c'est quoi votre votre secret j'ai pas
de secret je suis né comme ça avec cette
séduction extraordinaire c'était plus de
féminité et ce talent à tout casser j'y
peux rien c'est comme ça c'est la vie
ophélie vous vous trouvez commandant
mauvais esprits super parce que être
odieuse comme ça et rester quand même
belle élégante et faut le faire j'ai lu
ce n'est fait ophélie aller comment
maria pacôme dans le film elle est pas
mal et maria pacôme
elle a bien supporté la canicule au
séchage ouais non non non non
m
[Applaudissements]
voilà
un peu je le vis tu n'as rien tu as
comme décidément j'aurais été arrosés
par les plus grandes
cet énorme arrêt et le théâtre felli
vous y pensez j'hésite
j'ai un peu peur
le savoir le moment je continue la
chanson ce n'est quand même ce que je
préfère et vos projets dans les années
qui viennent c'est quoi vous achetez un
jean taille basse
je ne sais pas vous cédez vous poser une
question
pour le moment je vis au jour le jour je
pense que là je vais être très apprécié
dans ce que je viens de faire enfin j'ai
prouvé je suis une comédienne jusqu'à
l'iss était petit et pas on avait été
assez dur avec moi je pense que là on va
voir qui je suis ophélie est ce que vous
pouvez nous chanter un petit bout de
comment c'est tout le monde le fait mais
non je connais pas ce truc là tout le
monde le fait pas vraiment apaisé sur la
masturbation fait mal à la tête mais
parra voilà voilà
[Musique]